Oh
uncle itch is a glitch nope nope um
starts off there's a glitch in the
episode the end it's the ugliest thing
I've ever seen um I tend to kind of
agree it's the worst my wife the
abstract artist it's for watching this
like gave her a whole new respect for
this show it's just like really really
it's I will say this watching it I was
at times I was saying to myself like is
this brilliant or awful and then it sort
of transferred into no this is really
annoying like it's my head hurts so much
after watching and I like stuff like
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas okay I
like stuff like Eraserhead and I'm just
watching this like oh it's all your life
in minutes I mean you met a half-hour of
this Oh a bitch oh yeah sis no pretty
much I mean there's a bit more it's it's
all CG it looks eg anime as well well
yeah um it looked really bright on arm
on this TV what was that it don'ts in
the comments below because like Ice King
we couldn't even see his face it was so
white you know we're wondering cuz I was
gonna say the colour pedal it was
terrible while wondering if it was i
wanna if it's just the copy weekend or
something or is it like that really
quickly people the first time i got
glitch is a glitch i got it from a
torrent site and i'm like ok cuz it
wasn't out it wasn't available anywhere
it's not available on DVD and I'm like I
need to see this yeah together so I
downloaded and I started watching it and
I thought there was something wrong with
it
because of all the crap that would
happen I'm like did I just get really
bad copy or whatnot and then I thought
no
this is exactly what it's supposed to be
like oh yeah it's supposed to be rise
King you can barely make out it sounds
like yeah um which I thought was a very
poor choice in color yeah it's well you
know it's it's adventure time in CG and
okay I've gone on on I prefer hand-drawn
to CG but but see she's fine
you know I mean it's created some
beautiful landscapes and you know
there's a lot of great CG films Zillah
I like how this way you're trying and I
like you know a lot a lot of the
dreamwork stuff and everything
Despicable Me really those are the two
that won you over out of all that all CG
folks are so bad but Despicable Me
that's what we found but oh but but case
in point
you saw how colourful and bright and
imaginative is that that could be why
waste that opportunity with Adventure
Time Adventure Time CG what you can do
with this and it's it's a good idea I
love the idea of like just the universe
has a glitch you know and it was given
by the the Ice King and they serve go -
oh wow this is like the universe's uh
you know not source code it's like I
think that's a fun idea you know and
even like at first when I'm looking at
all the little glitches of seven like oh
this is kind of clever and it really
looks like you know it's all pixelated
stuff but when you find out it's the
whole thing it's like oh my god you know
and I don't
again it's nauseating I don't think it's
it's gonna sound strange I don't think
even for adventure time its abstract
enough to be no it's a fact enough to be
like wow that was brilliant
and pure surrealism and stuff because
it's like it was mostly I don't know
nothing seemed like challenging about
nothing seemed like you know hey here's
something that's gonna sort of you know
question you and challenge you has it's
just annoying and again from someone who
loves Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas and
loves
can take things that are annoying but
it's sort of raising questions and it's
sort of challenging this just didn't
seem to do that it was sort of one joke
they had a few good you know variations
I love the one second later that was
grossie and that's where I'd have to do
you see I love that the reason why it
bothers me is because it wasn't one
second that's why I like it said ten
seconds later and it literally waited
ten seconds that would have been funnier
to me no see my eyes I like the FF it
just once I can lay there and you hold
on it for a solid like thirty seconds
and said that bad I thought with brother
Jimmy all the comedy felt cheap all the
comedy felt incredibly long and
drawn-out like every single joke they
were doing like they couldn't do
Adventure Time is boom boom very fast
jokes sometimes you don't even catch a
joke when it happens and this one felt
like the writer the creator whoever he
was can do that oh we're gonna do the
whole donut guy running around and
spazzing about you know his face and
then of course that's gonna happen for a
good minute I know at the end we can't
think of another joke so we're never
running around spazzing doing the same
thing we're gonna have the hare eating
which by the way the guy who did this
one
that's his video apparently he created
that girl eating the hare video so he
tossed his own work into adventure time
and then at the same time I felt
incredibly cheap then it was basically
his own work that saved the day
well now he's putting a glitch in this
video obviously because we already Clips
there I thought I was very cheap a lot
of this stuff was very cheap the jokes
weren't all that great bubble gum
hitting the computer and over and over
again hit it for once or twice okay I
would have been flying 12 times I got
bored
jaqen PB yeah quite well in medicine
yeah it's a good daddy and he loves ring
but his hand we don't know
it's you know and for its that was
written and directed by the same guy
what was it do you know the story behind
that always it's just a guy they found
says a guy who worked on the staff
there's a few episodes once coming up
called James Baxter the horse and then
there's one of the newest season coming
up where they get kind of like guest
animators to come in and make the road
episodes okay now I want to see this and
I know people are gonna yell at me or
bring yellow to yell at the screen
before I bring it up this is a this is
glitch is a glitch is not part of the
Canon
it's not a Canon episode it's just its
own thing yeah it's kind of there and
the whole you said you know Jake is a
good dad he loves Rainicorn you know it
doesn't matter this has nothing to do
with anything and I feel that's kind of
stupid it's like why what's the point of
it being this is like one of the only
non canon episodes i think well what was
the wand ever is never really brought up
but it's social evening can be canon
yeah easy fits in there because it
doesn't break any of the laws or rules
the glitch is a glitch just kind of felt
like I don't know we go from this guy
who who we like his work we brought him
on board to make an episode and this is
what he comes up with you know it's I'm
really a fan of when people they
experiment in the show and this show is
so good at experimenting and trying you
know different things is so often they
work uh and that you're just always
gonna get one that just doesn't quite
hit it at least for me it doesn't quite
hit it uh you know and again I just want
the sighs I love Ren and Stimpy I love I
love surreal humor and I love say yeah I
look forget Adventure Time and I like
when they do something different uh but
this just constantly just seemed like
you know more of the same and and it's
annoying what they throw at you over and
over it's not like you know hey here's
here's a lot of the same and we're gonna
see how long we can start push it it's
like it's that and it's incredibly i
bleeding ly annoying and
you know like when you first see they're
talking to like whatever a whole bunch
of glitches there and they're yelling at
me
taking it throw it and it has a face you
know I'm like oh that's kind of clever
another guy go up to the head glitch and
it's the exact same thing except it has
like a beard I'm saying like what why
don't you save that for the head glitch
yeah you know why give it away uh at
least once in a while there's something
I kind of like I like when the glitch
talks and it says the subtitle but that
one yeah and a jig look at its back
where it's like stuff like that like
that's kind of quiet like I say I mean I
know you guys didn't like the one second
later it's like I kind of did you know I
understand why yeah it's it's not that
there's nothing in this episode there's
one or two ideas that's like okay that's
thinking out of the box and kind of
creative before a show that's already
doing that and yeah it's so well and
doing it so smart and clever and
unexpected and quick and and so well
paced uh yeah this just did not seem to
gel it seems like it was trying too hard
is trying too hard to be different like
what I was but it was it wasn't even
good CG that's what's so strange and so
many shows are CG now you know and some
are good some are bad but it's like this
one like sometimes the movements nice
you know like when PB is destroying the
computers like that was good movement
but yeah I mean they all look very fake
which I'm sure was the idea but it's
like why I think I think it was
purposely made shitty I think this is
like a really silly in joke with the guy
that did it
she raised up a really good point if you
think about it the end where
everything's kind of like roots
reloading I'm looking at any of that
stuff like think about the episode how
much of this is anything that's happened
before like what they're doing the whole
point like out and all that stuff to the
reload screen there was nothing there
from adventure time that I ever saw
before the three but man the weird guy
like that all seems like I think Jory
it's right like a bunch of inside jokes
of this guy or stuff that this guy's
created
and it's kind of like forcing it into
the universe well and what Adventure
Time usually does is that it balances
stuff you haven't seen yet but are going
to wait with just sort of strange stuff
but you're right nothing nothing and
those things backing out or really a lot
of it seeing the light that this was
adventure time you know or something you
see in Adventure Time uh the one thing I
kinda like when to point out I like we
saw the galaxy it just gets a little
windy like that again just serve like
the source code of the universe it's
like I like I like the idea so it's yeah
I think it's it's not I don't think it's
a bad idea and I think there's one or
two jokes that are just out of the box
enough that it got a laugh but you know
it gave me a headache
I just wish one I just wish normally
you're like there's a joke that was
missed and you say what it is I feel
kind of the same way with this it should
have started normal animation normal
animation and then the moment they put
in the disk is - when it starts going to
CG kind of like that disk starts the
glitch right then and there and then it
starts kind of getting like weird and
bizarre after that yeah there's a number
of explanation why it's CG
yeah and that's I think part of the
reason why I was yeah I mean it's I I
don't know it's so you know maybe the
guy could just be like it's I understand
why people can like this and we yeah
it's bizarre it's strange it's different
you can see it kind of it's a troll
episode there's two in this for a troll
episode I'll even say that you know that
it's not so bad cuz it's still kind of
you know like so where two of those
jokes are pretty strange and out of the
box and it still took CG animation as
much as I you know sometimes complain
about is not easy you know it's still
really difficult to do and this is you
know comprehensive enough to show okay
there's definitely effort that went into
it just not all their effort to care and
not too little to laugh at it you know I
think it was a lot of effort to make it
look shitty it's like those idiots that
buy like ripped jeans for seven
already ripped jeans I think it's a
perfect analogy we want you good episode
please oh my god what's up now let's do
that yeah we'll see yeah good episode
thank goodness